We are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50.
I want to go to our caller from mousex 1 2
area code caller from 6 1 2. What anything?
Where are you calling from?
David, it's Chris from New York. Live from
the epicenter. How you doing? Good. How are
you?
Not too bad. So over the last couple days,
we've all been seeing the people, the spring
breakers like doing the. You know, very embarrassingly
reckless news conferences like them not caring
about, you know, spreading the diseases. And
I remember you said it's like at their face
or that they look policy and burned.
But some of them did. Yes, some of them I
mean, they're faceless. It was weird. The
spring breakers, their faces were all like
bruised and burned while they were they were
giving the press conferences, which didn't
suggest to me that they were the best people
to go to for advice on self-preservation.
Yeah, the one bro with like the backwards
hat in the summer base. Yeah. My question
was basically during the AIDS epidemic. I
know people were getting prosecuted for knowingly
spreading a disease. Right. Could you see
a world where during this corona virus epidemic,
people do end up going to prison for knowingly
spreading the epidemic?
Well, listen, I think that it's completely
impossible that that's going to happen for
someone who's just like at the beach. You
know, I I just don't see that. I do believe
that if a governor issues an order of nothing
over 20 people and you've got 200 people at
a concert, someone should pay the price for
that. Now, I don't know if it's the venue,
if it's the individuals who go, if it's every
I don't know what the answer is to that. But
if you've got a governor with it, with something
that says no, no events over a certain amount,
there probably should be some consequence
to that. Now, let me take it a step further,
though. We now have reports that teenagers
are finding it funny to go to grocery stores
and cough on produce. Right. The idea being
maybe they've got coronavirus and they're
putting it on your apples if they cough on
it or whatever.
Right. And I actually think there is a guy
in one day or the kids, they're spitting on
old ladies saying they have Carone virus.
Right.
Obviously, that smells like spitting on someone
is already at least in the U.S. in arrestable
offense. Coughing unproduced. There's probably
some statute that says that that's. So we've
got to just enforce that stuff.
Right. Because, I mean, I could see a world
where people start getting a real black killed
sense of nihilism and they get corona virus
and they go out and they they knowingly want
to infect people.
Yeah. You know, in your world, let's say,
David, is that you're the DOJ. Right. Like,
if you know, people are doing this, like,
what is the sentence for these people?
I don't know. I don't know what the sentences.
But certainly if you found out that someone
had tested positive and was violating a quarantine
and was going around coughing and spitting
on people, obviously the spitting is already
criminal. And you've got to figure out what
is the additional thing, you know? What are
you. There must be. I'm sure there is some
law that could be thrown at them that already
exists that would apply to what they're doing.
I sure hope so, because, I mean, it's looking
like people are taking it more seriously.
But again, I just wish people would really
hunker down and stop being reckless.
I agree with you. And that's why, you know,
Trump now talking about letting a rip and
filling churches on Easter seems like a very
dangerous thing to be talking about. Oh, my
God.
He went on that diatribe. He's like the churches.
They're going to be so full. It's gonna be
so beautiful. Yeah. Just making me think of
Philly in 1918 when they had that big bond
parade.
It's it's absolutely crazy to be thinking
about it. And, you know, hopefully somebody
will talk him out of it soon.
I sure hope so. Well, thank you, David.
All right, my friend. Thank you. Great to
hear from you. Appreciate it.